hay muchas cosas
así como a ver
soy esposa de un hombre increíble que
por cierto está presentado gracias amor
por estar contigo siempre
soy madre de dos adolescentes que por
cierto están insoportables pero los amo
soy publicista por elección así lo
decidí amo mi carrera hago mi trabajo
es poco tiempo trabajando y la verdad es
que es increíble
pero sobre todo soy mujer
esa es mi esencia
eso es lo que me hace hoy estar aquí con
ustedes
porque yo
ellos son mis hijos luis enrique y
daniel héctor mi esposo
y ellos han sido un pilar muy importante
en mi vida
esta soy yo
como les dicen
antes que otras cosas soy mujer
hace 5 años
aproximadamente
en mi vida cotidiana subir bajar los
hijos la escuela el trabajo
me recosté
y me pegué una almohada sobre el pecho
algo pasó
no me dolió
molesto
y me preocupé mucho
cliente como pueden ver aquí no voy a
hacer un ultrasonido
y el viernes de esta misma semana me
estaban haciendo mi primera operación
disculpen la foto de la operación está
muy fea pero era lo que alguien
y así para
de operar como
y había que esperar dos semanas
para esperar los resultados
dos semanas de miedo
la angustia de temor
de no saber qué iba a pasar yo no sabía
que era lo que tenía
pero algo en el fondo de mi corazón y de
mi ser
lo sabía
algo no estaba bien
y qué pasa cuando uno se inunda de todos
estos sentimientos
empiezas a perder la cabeza empiezas a
pensar cosas
pues te has
cuando me entregan el resultado
me diagnostican cáncer de mama
35 años también
porque ellos
no era posible
mi familia no había cáncer
tiene 35 años
esta enfermedad yo pensaba que era
por qué
amor
y empiezas a pensar de cuestionarte que
hice para merecer
estoy en plena juventud mis hijos
creciendo
una vida excelente con altas y bajas con
problemas como todos pero esto a mi edad
aquí
cuando yo escuchaba la palabra cáncer
pues yo sabía qué significaba muerte
y si yo pensé que me iba a morir
y algo muy dentro de mí
me gritaba
no te vas a morir no te puedes morder
no puede ser
aunado a esto pues bueno no me quedó de
otra más que ponerme cara a cara con la
enfermedad vamos a agarrar valor
y tomar decisiones decisiones que no
quería tomar que no sabía ni cómo tomar
y que no las pude haber tomado sola sin
el apoyo de mi familia que ellos fueron
el pilar ellos fueron los que estuvieron
conmigo
tú estaba derrumbar
todo se calle
tomamos la decisión y lo tomamos porque
mi esposo me ha enseñado a hablar en
plural
si yo no hubiera podido tomar esa
decisión sólo lo hice gracias a ellos a
mis hijos
la toma de decisiones consta
de dejar ir mi esencia lo que me hace
mujer
decidimos que me tengo que quitar los
dos senos para poder seguir viva
y pues si así fue bien en una operación
me quitan los dos senos en la misma
operación me ponen implantes plantes fue
idea del esposo
no porque quisiera verme
muy voluptuosa
él me dijo y ya eso me los implantes
porque él creía y estaba seguro
que mi recuperación iba a ser en un 80%
en mi autoestima y claro que por
supuesto que el fuego
pensándolo no sé que hubiera hecho si no
se hubieran podido poner los implantes
hubiera sido mucho más difícil
pasan 15 días me toca consulta con el
médico yo tenía el cabello pues a media
espalda decidió cortar me lo muy
chiquito llegó con el doctor y le digo
bueno doctor ya hicimos la operación
yo pensando pues las quimioterapias eso
es lo que sí
efectivamente el doctor me dice que sí
que vamos a tener un tratamiento y pues
le digo lo que sigue
yo con mucho miedo
desde que iba a quedar calva
pero a final de cuentas eso era lo que
menos importaba importaba estar aquí
el doctor me dice
no
tú no necesitas ni una quimioterapia
no necesitas radioterapia lo único en lo
que va a constar tu tratamiento es una
pastilla diaria de aquí a cinco años y
tus revisiones cada tres meses
y saber cómo
espéreme
se supone que a la gente que le da
cáncer le tienen que dar quimioterapias
pues no
me di cuenta
que esta fe a la que me amarré esta fe
que no hablemos de religión vamos de
este interna que uno quiere
esta fe es la que me llevo
hasta la sangre
yo sabía que no me iba a morir
que solo tenía más que claro
esa es una foto donde voy a pedir por mi
salud y yo estoy segura que ese fue el
día que surgió el milagro ese fue el día
que
muy internamente pensé que porque quería
ser vivida
y pues bueno obviamente con mis hijos y
mi esposo que era mi principal motor
qué es lo que me salvó aparte de esa fe
y actitud
yo creo que esta enfermedad es 100%
actitud si tú te derrumbas si tú te caes
y tú te ves pues obviamente te
desesperas
empiezas a tener malos pensamientos
yo fui muy positiva tan positiva que
todo el mundo llegado a mi casa mis
amigas ellas serán las que lloraban
mi mamá todos sentaban y señoras
lloraban junto a mí
y yo les dije no
si van a venir a verme yo no quiero que
vengan a sentarse a que llora
porque yo no lo hice porque yo no me lo
permite
porque yo no quise derrumbar
si yo voy a decir que era mucho
a oscuras en la cama abrazada de mi
esposo
pero al día siguiente sale el sol y me
levantaba
y salía con la frente en alto
sabiendo que no me iba a morir
yo estoy segura que estoy aquí
por algo
y yo estoy segura de que voy a llegar a
la vida de muchas personas
los
algunos meses
y ese es el objetivo no sólo llegar a
las mujeres porque esto no es una
enfermedad de cualquier persona
es poco activo ahora me entero que las
niñas de 25 años están enfermando
también
yo quiero llegar a todos a los hombres a
las mujeres
quiero compartir con ustedes este vídeo
en donde lo venden
a causa del tiempo
vamos a día
ese día sentí que algo estaba mal y no
el día que me diagnosticaron cáncer
pues claro
me viene a la mente el pasado
y
todo mundo
era muy
bien
tenían
[Música]
como todos
como conoces algún grupo
por tanto
y necesito
es que hoy estoy
y
yo soy más movimiento
yo soy uno mucho más
[Música]
esa es mi invitación al día de hoy que
reflexionemos
que sepamos que tenemos muchos problemas
en la vida pero la actitud es lo que te
saca
la actitud y el estar con tu familia con
la gente que te quiere
yo escribí hace poquito
es una frase que me gusta mucho yo la
inventé porque yo cada octubre participó
en algo para
para la prevención del cáncer y yo estoy
convencida de que las mujeres tenemos
que luchar hasta el final con amor y
valencia
yo soy diana martínez y se sobreviviente
de cáncer de mama
[Aplausos]